oh that's this is just wrong shaq's
penis is kevin hart
what was your dream job when you were
kids speed round first thing that comes
to your mind nba player deep sea diver
mermaid
fireman hooker i mean
you want to take over the the samantha
role yeah
i can do it you sure because you don't
seem like her at all i'm pretty much
exactly the same but do you want to see
yes i do want to see it this is it
i love
and something that you know i've been so
frustrated i knew this was going to
happen
so i heard about this last night i'm
getting the bit over with jonah's got a
fart machine no you should see the way
we all looked at him
what is going on i was like do i finish
the question
i acknowledge that he just farted what
has been your favorite quote from any
spider-man film
i'm watching porn
one years later i just call my office no
jackie i want you to do the karate kid i
said okay
who's the teacher
i i thought i'm the clown again
i already forget how old i am
i still think i'm the kid he said no
you're the teacher i said what oh
[Applause]
check it
why these ballers try to be like me if
this was hip-hop i'm b.i.g
i'm b.i.g
nick milaj will you marry me
oh she said no
man messing up the flow so that'll make
him not
your superhero character is called
captain marvel yes
well they really have stopped trying
haven't they
i mean why don't they just call it
captain comic book or captain we can't
think of anything else complete dwayne's
twitter bio
chivalrous gentlemen
just add
[ __ ]
complete kevin's twitter bio my name is
kevin hart and i am a piece of [ __ ] come
on
stop it that's not a piece
of in my what's the easiest way to make
money the first million is the hardest
to make yeah right so start with the
second million right
hello
it was supposed to be funny guys come on
wake up
i think we have a breakfast show here
i was like a circus act
did you get bullied bullied did i get
bullied yeah
yes yes i did get bullied
um why
what was that my parents uh were cool
i'm sorry other children were very kind
okay okay
my parents are like look at him he's a
freak
when did you realize at what age did you
realize that you were good at fighting
ham well what agenda i mean i'm irish
we're all good
i bet anne hathaway has a weird vagina
well you'll never know russ d dillon
could you ever tour an album um you do
it down actually adele gave me a top tip
she was like yeah whenever you can't hit
the high note you're just like you're
like
you have a other character that you do i
have one and i'll show it to you right
now it's called the understanding
scotsman you can just sort that into any
movie spielberg soderbergh
i can't think of any other director
okay this is the understanding scotsman
yeah
i understand
wouldn't be here without them without my
team and certainly not without my family
rock on a serious note can you tell us
when the show premieres
the show premieres it doesn't matter
when the show premieres
why does everybody want to get so
quiet jesus christ
he can't eat the fish
get him out of london now
what just happened just now
well i make this baby voice that really
freaks out my friends and my boyfriend
all the time and like it's kind of fun
for me to make them super uncomfortable
i was just like voice makes your
boyfriend uncomfortable yeah okay oh i'm
just a little baby i'm just your little
baby girl
oh my god that would just
yes i could see why that would upset
i got hit in the face so like uh
fragment portion of it is in my tongue
so it kind of changed the way i speak a
little bit it's still in your tongue can
you see it yeah it's great for oral sex
[Music]
it was so famous he had to disguise
himself and we would come downstairs i'd
be like where's michael michael be
covered up like i'm over here chris from
here
michael that's you yeah christian so
we're going to movies and i'm thinking
you know i'm trying to be secret too you
know i'm hiding myself then michael
laughing louder than anybody everybody
know michael's laughing right
i was like michael shut up zendaya
you're taller than tom and it became
this this thing and i thought
well
that much more
she's put this out there
maybe like an inch or two
it's not like people say like like how
did you guys kiss has been so difficult
the atlanta braves brought home their
first championship in 26 years
over a million people turned off for the
parade and after waiting three hours for
it to start
this is what they saw
ah
[Music]
[Laughter]
that may be the funniest clip that we've
seen all day they going like 35.
[ __ ] do they know what a parade for
yo
what do they tell the drivers no matter
what under no conditions do you slow
this [ __ ] down
but this is the parade we supposed to
see the people i'm gonna [ __ ] what it
is you drive this [ __ ] through there
until we get to a place where i feel
like it's safe
hey they did three five four running
through that [ __ ] jesus christ
do you see the people like what the [ __ ]
is going on i'm crying laughing because
they was going so fast oh my god man and
you you love bruce lee you idolized
bruce lee you had a chance to work with
him but i understand it didn't go so
smoothly when you did yeah uh and that
time he was a huge star what's up i was
a low-class stuntman you know i remember
that scene he was a fight five five five
five suddenly he picked me up the last
one i'm the last one then he have the
two stick ah then and hit me then i fall
down that's okay rehearsal
come on boom okay
then by the time you're coming rolling
action everybody's so exciting i was
waiting waiting waiting
for come out
i just feel
so many stars
the long sleeve just right here
no
as a stun guy we get used to the heat i
got boom i did i i
knock me down i get i just i pick see
what he's doing you know he just
turned around he walked
right after
he walked away caught i just tried to
get up i just see bruce
throw this oh my god you know i was
scared up like this i see him oh my god
i pretend i pretend
but it doesn't hurt but i'm more hurt
then he just come over again i thought
yeah i'm okay okay
the whole day whatever filming and every
shot you turn around
i said
that motion every time you see me i just
was well worth it yeah that was so so
nice to hit by bruce lee
[Applause]